[MUSIC PLAYING]
EVAN JONES: Hi.
I'm Evan Jones
with Google Cloud,
and I'm really excited
to have Joy with us here.
She is a data educator and a
supervisor at the Children's
Hospital of Philadelphia.
Welcome to the show, Joy.
JOY PAYTON: Thank you.
It's great to be here.
EVAN JONES: Yeah,
it's really exciting.
A lot of things are happening
virtually these days,
and interviews are
just one of them,
but thankfully, we both
have really good internet
connections.
And we've got a treasure
trove of questions to ask you,
particularly about certification
and your background.
Do you mind if we just jump in?
JOY PAYTON: Yeah, fantastic.
Let's go.
EVAN JONES: All right.
Tell me a little
bit about yourself
and what brought you
to this certification,
and how it's related to your
work, if you don't mind.
JOY PAYTON: Sure.
So as you stated, I work
for the Children's Hospital
of Philadelphia.
And we are a customer of
Google Cloud platform,
as well as other
cloud providers.
And two years ago, I was
sent to Google Cloud Next,
which was a great opportunity.
and I really enjoyed it.
And as part of the
lead-up to the conference,
I received an email
inviting me to consider
applying for this diversity
cohort that was intended
to help broaden the appeal and
broaden the class of people
who were certified as
Google Cloud experts.
And that was something
that really appealed to me.
And it appealed to me
because, number one,
for my own professional
growth and education,
I thought that would
be very useful for me--
EVAN JONES: Absolutely.
JOY PAYTON: --yeah,
as well as the fact
that I am a data educator, and
it's really important to me
to multiply everything that
I'm able to do and teach
others and deputize them, in
turn, to train still others.
So it just seemed like
it was a real opportunity
to, in my local community,
at the Children's Hospital
of Philadelphia and
beyond, to really grow
some education around
cloud computing.
EVAN JONES: What would
you say to those folks who
hear the word examination
or certificate,
and they might not have a
strong background in data
or have the technical
skills, but they look at you
and they say, you know, if
she can do it, I can do it,
let's go do this thing.
I'm going to sign up.
I'm going to be the next
cohort that's coming out, Joy.
What would you say
to those people
who have a little bit
of-- at Google, we
call it imposter syndrome,
which is you walk into a room,
and you feel like
everyone else in the room
is smarter than you,
has done all this,
and they deserve to be
here, and you might not.
You feel like you
don't belong there,
even though absolutely, with
everything of their core being,
they need to be there
and they should be there.
How would you
motivate those people
that are going to be joining
that next cohort after you?
What would you say to them?
JOY PAYTON: Well, I
have two sound bites.
One is, don't believe
everything you think.
EVAN JONES: I like that one.
JOY PAYTON: So just
because you think
this is beyond your
skills or you're
too far behind
because you're over 50
or you never worked
with computers,
or whatever the reason is, don't
believe everything you think.
And also, if you're the
smartest person in the room,
you are in the wrong room.
EVAN JONES: I love that one.
JOY PAYTON: You need to be
with people that are smarter
than you and know more
than you, and start
being comfortable with
being uncomfortable.
I think that's something
in this current--
this is being filmed during
the COVID-19 pandemic,
and a lot of us are getting
comfortable with being
uncomfortable.
And that's a real life lesson.
So I will say that imposter
syndrome I don't think ever
really goes away, but I have
learned to talk back to it.
And one of the
things that I find--
because I've taught technology
to children and adults,
and one of the things
that I've noticed
is the emergence of
the confidence gap.
And in my experience,
this happens
around fifth or sixth
grade, where some people,
predominantly boys,
although not exclusively,
feel very confident
in math and science,
and when they run
across challenges,
like a really hard
math problem-- so math
starts getting really hard
around sixth, seventh grade,
right?
When they run across
a hard math problem,
they think to themselves,
wow, this is a hard problem.
I am super smart for
tackling this hard problem.
And then there's a group
of students, predominantly,
but not exclusively
girls, who maybe,
because they've done well
in school up to this point
without as much effort, realize
that, wow, this is much more
effort than I'm accustomed to.
I must not be up to the task.
And that confidence gap I still
continue to see in people.
And it's interesting
to me because I work
with very, very smart people.
I work with people
who are MD/PhDs.
I work with students
who are in grad school
at Yeshiva, who are
adult learners who
have important full-time jobs.
I work with very
smart people, and they
have imposter syndrome.
And they feel like,
wow, this is hard.
And I wrote some
code, and it failed.
And what they don't
realize because they're not
in this industry is, in
tech, you fail all the time.
You fail and you
fail and you fail.
And you finally succeed, but
you don't get to rest in it
and roll around in
how wonderful it
is because you've got to
go on to the next thing
and start failing again.
And that's not like most jobs.
So I do a lot of soft
skills, and helping
people get comfortable
with failure
and get comfortable with
not being great at things.
You're not going to be great
at this when you start.
And that's fine.
You're not supposed to be great.
So hang in there,
you're going to be fine,
don't panic when
you make a mistake,
and don't believe
everything you think.
EVAN JONES: I think
that's perfect, Joy.
I love the get comfortable
being uncomfortable.
Even to this day, I
mean, a lot of people
look at the folks
who work at Google
and, oh, you've got a job
at Google, that's like--
you know, everyone
there is a genius
and writing the next
self-driving car application
or something like that.
I can tell you,
every day, there's
a moment where I'm like--
you're running into
that same type of wall,
that same type of
wall where you're
in fifth grade or sixth
grade, and you're up
against a math problem
or a technical problem
or an interpersonal problem,
and you feel a little bit
of that uncomfortability.
And I couldn't +1 or
agree with your point more
of it's the step
that you take next.
It's either you're going
to run away from that,
or you're going to say it's all
right to feel uncomfortable,
but I'm still going
to do this anyways.
I think that's a perfect
message out there.
All right, the certification.
I would love to ask you a
few more questions on that,
if you don't mind.
JOY PAYTON: Sure.
EVAN JONES: How has the
certification itself either
impacted the
organization you work for
or the communities
that you're a part of?
JOY PAYTON: Sure.
I mean, especially as
an adjunct professor,
it's very important to me that
the education that I'm giving
my students is the
most cutting edge,
because it might take them
two, three, four years--
these are adult learners
who are very busy--
to finish their master's degree,
which means that, by the time
they leave, what I taught them
their first year is already
a couple of years
out of date, right?
So I want to make
sure that, the day I
deliver that lecture
or share that Colab
notebook, that it is the most
up-to-date I can possibly do.
And so I do a lot of
advocating with senior folks
at my education institution,
at Yeshiva University,
for adopting cloud
platforms and saying,
this is where our students
are going to be working.
So sure, they should
certainly install Python
on their laptops, absolutely.
You know, if you want to have
a SQL server spun up someplace
on campus, that's great, too.
But realistically,
as far as job skills,
our students are going to
be working in the cloud.
So how can we really leverage
my skills and whatever topic
I'm teaching, whether that's
learning to program in Python
or doing computer vision or
some sort of data engineering
or data pipelines.
No matter what sort
of topic I'm teaching,
there's a way to tie it to
cloud in a way that really
is building students' abilities
to understand the vocabulary
to be able to be
autodidacts, right?
To have the terminology,
to know the concepts
well enough to know
what to search for.
You know, I always say that
so much of what I teach
is telling people what
to Google, and helping--
EVAN JONES: Absolutely.
JOY PAYTON: --people learn
how to Google, right?
And I also tell
people, you know what,
I Google this every day, too.
So if you think that I have
the syntax memorized, I do not.
And--
EVAN JONES: People
always get surprised--
so I do a lot of
BigQuery and SQL courses,
and they always
get surprised when
I'm presenting in
the classroom and I'm
going to Google to look up,
like, some of these functions.
They're like, wait a minute, you
presented on an online platform
with ease and I'm like, I
don't memorize this stuff,
but I know where to look.
Absolutely.
Couldn't agree more.
JOY PAYTON: Yeah,
so I mean, that's
my life as an adjunct professor.
I would also say,
I've had people
come to me at work or just in
the community and say, hey,
I saw on LinkedIn that you
are Google Cloud certified.
I want to find out
more about this.
And these are often
career changers or people
who discovered,
to their surprise,
that they really liked DevOps
or platform engineering
or some of the
background engineering.
And maybe that wasn't the
job that they were hired for,
but they realized that, wow,
I have some technical skills
and abilities that
I didn't know about.
And in fact, I had a
conversation with someone
who has a lot of information
science experience,
but is not a programmer.
She would not consider
herself a programmer.
And she said, can I pursue this?
I said absolutely, right?
You know, there are specialty,
professional-grade exams
for applications developers,
but this initial associate-level
exam is just a great overview
of lots of different things.
And I said, if nothing else,
what it will do is give you
a chance to learn a lot,
figure out what parts you like
and what parts you don't.
For example, I am so
grateful that there
are network engineers.
I thank my lucky stars
for them every day
because I could
not do their job.
Right?
EVAN JONES: I feel the same way.
Any questions that
I ever get on,
like, IP addresses and routing,
like, private network traffic,
I'm like, ooh.
JOY PAYTON: I mean, I look up
how do you write a CIDR block
notation, you know, probably--
EVAN JONES: Every time.
Every time.
JOY PAYTON: --at
least once a quarter.
You know, sometimes it'll stick
around for a little while.
So one of the things,
you know, I've
had a very circuitous
career path.
And along the way, I took
10 years out of technology
to do full-time volunteer work.
And so I worked in prisons and
schools and homeless shelters
in Spain and Bolivia
and El Salvador.
And one of the things that
I really fell in love with
was the power of education
to change people's lives
at every level, right?
I worked with women who spoke
only their indigenous language,
did not speak Spanish, maybe
only spoke Quechua or Aymara
in Bolivia, and
realizing that just
their inability to speak
Spanish kept them out
of the marketplace.
It kept them impoverished.
It kept them under the control,
sometimes, of domestic abusers.
And all the way up
to people that I
saw in prison who were
getting degrees and making
their lives better.
And so I've come back
to full-time work
because I love technology
and I love education,
and I'm lucky enough
to combine the two.
And at the end of
the day, what I
would love to do is go back
into some of these lower
resourced areas
and say, hey, NGOs,
I would like to help
you boost your signal.
Let's take a look at your data.
How can you be in charge
of your data story?
How can I help you?
There are resources that
I can connect you with.
And not only can I help you,
NGO, but can I also help
the community you serve?
What's the population you serve?
What are they like?
Because the wonderful
thing about technology
is it's not the formal degrees
you have, it's what you can do.
And this is one of
the few industries,
I feel like, that that
continues to be true for.
And knowing that I have the
skills in Google Cloud Platform
to help other people
at all levels,
including people with
very low literacy,
computer literacy, that
they can access this stuff
through a URL.
They need a strong
internet connection,
which is not nothing,
that can be challenging,
but with just a strong internet
connection and a Chromebook
or a low-powered
laptop, I can really
help someone grow in skills that
will help them make a living,
help them provide
for their families,
and also improve the
lot of organizations
in under-resourced
areas that are doing
really important, good things.
So--
EVAN JONES: That's so--
JOY PAYTON: --that's my dream.
EVAN JONES: --well said.
I love that dream.
And it's the dream
of Google as a whole.
Their core mission is to
make the world's information
universally accessible
to anyone and everyone.
You know, not just people
in the United States,
not just people of a certain
class or a certain privilege,
as well.
So it reminds me when you speak,
like the Chromebook and a URL
and the internet,
and they access
one of your IPython
notebooks and they're
doing a machine learning model
that would have previously
taken an entire Google data
center to do like 10 years ago,
now they're running on
their laptop in a cafe
or something like that, too.
Being able to access that
technology, and to your point,
to be able to access the
educational resources
and those badges, like
the certifications,
as well, is just such
a powerful story, Joy.
Thank you so much for sharing
not only your background,
but just the clear passion.
I thought I'm a
passionate person.
Listening to you just
gets me motivated to take
even more of these
certifications, as well.
I certainly don't have them all.
So thank you so, so much.
Any closing words from your
side to inspire the watchers?
JOY PAYTON: Oh, gosh.
Let me think.
Let me pause.
EVAN JONES: I put you
on the spot, I know.
I'm sorry.
JOY PAYTON: You did.
Let me think.
I'm usually pretty
quick on my feet, too.
EVAN JONES: No, I'll
say mine, and then we
can close with yours.
So mine, at Google,
we have a moniker,
and this is different than other
companies that I work with,
is good artists copy,
but great artists steal.
And so one of my favorite
things you mentioned
is these collaborative
notebooks for machine learning.
A lot of our courses
that I put out,
I draw inspiration from a
lot of the other works that
are out there.
Data science in
particular is meant
to be a community of
folks kind of achieving
a goal or an objective together.
So don't feel like you
need to go it alone,
especially if you're looking
at other people's resources,
as well.
And certainly,
internally at Google,
we're constantly stealing
each other's work
and making the insights
together, as well.
So all right, close us with
a pithy example or quote.
No pressure.
JOY PAYTON: So I come at
this from a data scientist's
perspective.
So other people may come to
GCP from a lot of interest
in high-performance computing
or sort of network resilience
or other issues or
areas of interest,
but I'm principally
a data scientist,
so I'm going to give you the
answer of a data scientist.
If you want to learn how to be
a data scientist because you
think this is interesting,
then you definitely
need to be involved
with Google Cloud
Platform, because one of
the best ways to learn data
is using big data.
And there is a great
set of resources for you
in Google Public data sets
in BigQuery, which is just
a great place to get started.
There's tons of tutorials
that'll help you there
that are available at no cost.
The hosting of the data
sets is at no cost.
And all the work that you need
to do can be done in free tier.
So there are lots of ways that,
even without participating
in a formal training process
or signing up for an exam,
that you can grow your
skills and really find a data
set that you're
passionate about.
I tell people, if you love
sports, look at sports data.
If you're concerned
about hunger and poverty,
look for those data sets.
Find something you care
about, and you will definitely
find some trends that
make you scratch your head
or make you angry
or make you excited
or make you ask questions.
So find some data, work with
it, and change the world.
EVAN JONES: I love it.
That's such a
great way to close.
All right, we have
Joy with us from CHOP,
which is the Children's
Hospital of Philadelphia.
Thank you so much
for taking this time
to talk a little bit
about [INAUDIBLE]
and your entire background
that's led you this far,
and carrying forward with
you for your students
and adult learners that you're
taking forward, as well.
Thank you so much.
JOY PAYTON: Thank you so
much for your time, as well.
This was great.
Be well.
[MUSIC PLAYING]